Today we're going to introduce
the concepts of material
breach and substantial
performance by exploring
Jacob and Young's versus Kent.
The opinion was written by
Benjamin Cardozo while he
was a judge on the New York
State Court of Appeals.
As some of you may know,
Cardozo went on to become a supreme court
justice and like justices Scalia and
Marshall Cardozo has a law
school named after him. Uh,
he also wrote the famous torts decision
in Paul's graph versus long island
railroad.
The plaintiff in this case is a
building company, Jacob and Young's,
which contracted to build a summer home
for the defendant to homeowner George
Kent.
The contract specified that all rot iron
pipe must be of Redding manufacturer.
The building company,
however,
ended up installing some pipe
made by other manufacturers.
After building was completed,
the defendant,
George Kent discovered the error and
demanded that the plumbing be redone
because most of the plumbing was
at that point in case in the walls.
The cost to the building
company of replacing the
plumbing would have been quite
high.
So they refuse to do the replacement.
Kent responded by
refusing to pay, uh, 3000,
$483 balance.
That was to do a out of $77,000,
uh,
for the overall construction contract.
Uh,
the procedural at the history,
a history of the case was like this.
The plaintiff builder's
sued for this $3,400.
Some odd, a balance. Uh,
the trial judge excluded evidence that
the pipe used was the same in quality,
appearance and market value and cost as
the Redding pipe that had been promised.
And the court directed a
verdict for the defendant.
The appellate court reversed and granted
a new trial and the instinct court
affirmed the appellate court and
again found for the plaintiff.
This case is often taught in introductory
contracts courses because it touches
on several important issues.
There are two main issues in the case.
Number one was the
installation of Redding pipe,
a constructive condition,
uh,
a condition precedent to the owner's
duty to pay the last installment.
And, uh, if it is a condition
precedent, then the defendant,
uh, uh, would have, uh,
no duty to pay any money.
I'm, the second issue is, is the measure
of damages for breach by the builder,
uh, of promising to put in Redding
pipe and not putting it in.
Should that measure damages be the cost
of performance or merely dimunition in
value?
In essence,
judge Cardoza helps determine both
the extent of the buyer is defensive,
right to lawfully withhold payment as
well as the extent of the buyers off
pensive,
right to sue for damages,
a party to a contract can help secure
her right to the other side's performance
by either withholding her own performance
or by affirmatively suing the other
side for damages.
These are the core defensive and offensive
protections that of contract law.
Let's examine examine these two issues.
In turn,
the first,
the defensive protection issue that
the court considered was whether the
installation of Redding pipe
is a constructive condition
to the owner's duty to
pay the last installment.
In other words,
can the defendant withhold payment just
because the pipe was not from the right
manufacturer?
The defendant argued that the installation
of Redding pipe and only reading pipe,
uh, it was a condition that
must be satisfied before, uh,
the buyer had a contractual duty to pay.
In essence,
the defendant wanted the court to apply
what's called the perfect tender rule.
If the perfect tender
rule had been applied,
the buyer would have
no duty to pay in less.
The builder's performance was perfect
Kardos or rejected the perfect tender
rule. Uh, in part because, uh, uh,
he wanted to avoid builder forfeiture
for innocent or trivial construction
breaches. If a builder even
makes a minuscule breach,
a minuscule mistake in construction
under the perfect tender rule,
the buyer can refuse to
pay for any of the work.
And the alternative to the perfect tender
rule is the independent promises rule.
If the buyer's promise to pay is deemed
to be an independent promise of the
builders promise to build,
then the buyer has an unconditional
contractual duty to pay regardless of the
builders performance.
The Independent promise rule eliminates
the buyer's defensive protection,
especially under the very old common law.
If a buyer had agreed to buy a
cart for a certain amount of money,
the buyer might have an obligation to pay,
even if the seller didn't show up
with the cart at the designated time.
Under the independent promises rule,
the buyers only legal recourse for seller
breach would be to affirmatively sue
the seller for damages.
So how do we decide if promises
are independent or dependent?
The opinion is somewhat
vague on this question.
Cardozo does tell us that some promises
are so plainly independent that they can
never be fairly, can uh, uh,
can never buy fair construction,
be conditioned on one and either
Cardozo refuses to apply the independent
promises rule,
possibly because it would encourage
builders to commit gross breaches.
You could, uh, uh,
not build the house well and still
the person would have to pay you.
Uh, uh, and their only recourse
would be going to court,
which a lot of buyers don't want to do.
So instead of applying either the
perfect tender rule or the independent
promises, rural Cardozo Crafts
and intermediate standard,
he tells us that some promises quote
though dependent and thus conditions when
there is a departure in point of substance
will be viewed as independent and
collateral when departure
is insignificant.
So here's a quiz was the defendant's
right to Redding pipe protected by a
defensive right not to pay and often
sieve right to sue for damages or both?
Well, apparently only inoffensive, right?
The court wrote and a emission,
both trivial and innocent will sometimes
be a tone for by allowance of the
resulting damage and will not always be
the breach of a condition to be followed
by a forfeiture.
This is a statement of what is called
the substantial performance role.
This substantial performance
rule has two prongs, can't,
has no duty to pay if there is a
willful breach or if there is less than
substantial performance.
In this case,
the court found that the plaintiff
substantially performed its side of the
contract by installing another pipe of
Brant pipe brand that was similar in
quality, uh, uh,
where a breach is trivial and innocent.
A breach may be a tone for by
allowance of just resulting damages.
What counts as substantial performance.
It is determined by considerations,
partly of justice and partly
of presumed intention.
The factors listed by the courts are
reflected in section two 41 of the
restatement.
Second,
they go to the issue of whether the
breach is sufficiently material such as
whether the injured party will be
deprived of the benefit which he or she
reasonably expected,
and the extent to which the behavior of
the party failing to perform or to offer
to perform comports with standards
of good faith and fair dealing.
Note that the substantial performance
rule is a middle ground between perfect
and unconditional, uh, duties to perform,
minimizing both seller
and buyer opportunism.
The willful breach prong helps assure
that the builder will not intentionally
Chisel on her promise to build.
While the substantial performance prong
helps assure that the buyer will not
refuse to pay for trivial,
uh, build their breaches.
The rule established in the case.
The substantial performance rule is an
outcome that is likely to be preferred by
both future sellers and future buyers.
Future sellers are aware of the myriad
of small breaches that are bound to occur
in a complex construction contract.
Future buyers realize the defendant
victory would cause future sellers to take
dramatic,
inefficient precautions,
creating time and expense
and raise the price, uh,
unreasonably or the sellers
might demand payment in advance,
uh,
to sure against loss and a similar suit.
Here's another quiz.
Can Future parties contract around
the substantial performance rule?
You Bet, yes, they can contract around it.
The court says that intense not otherwise
revealed may be presumed to hold in
contemplation of the reasonable
and probable. In other words,
a buyer with idiocy in idiosyncratic
preferences who really wants readying pipe
because grandparents say started the
company can request perfect tender by
revealing their preference
explicitly in the contract.
Putting the onus on the buyer makes sense
from an economic perspective because
the idiosyncratic buyer
is the least cost avoider.
It's cheaper for the buyer to speak up
then for the seller to speculate about
all of the possible idiosyncrasies.
This substantial performance rule resolves
the defense of rights issue in favor
of the builder, but what about
the offensive rights question?
The second question is what kind of
remedies are appropriate for the builders
breach?
The court held that when breaches not
willful and the cost to replace the pipe
is high.
The defendant is only entitled
to dimunition in Value Damages,
which in this case is nothing.
Recall that the dimunition in value
is nothing because the pipes actually
installed are equal in quality and value
to the Redding pipe that was promised.
So in this case,
with the cost of performing damages mean
the construction company would have had
to tear out the wall
and replace the pipes.
No.
The construction company can pay the
buyer money to be led out of its duty to
perform the incentive to modify the
contract and the presence of costs or
performance. Damages is an
example of Cosia and bargaining.
The Coase theorem is a highly
influential legal and economic theory.
It states that were transaction costs
are low and efficient allocation of
resources will take place regardless
of how entitlements are allocated here,
there's a cozy and incentive for the
seller to buy her way out of her duty to
sell to the original buyer.
So there's also an interesting issue in
this case involving the architect and
what's called the
certificate of completion.
The contract explicitly said that
the final payment was only do after
plaintiff's architect gave a certificate
of completed completion certifying that
the work had been done except for noting
that the architect failed to notice the
discrepancy in the pipe until
after the house was completed.
The court did not consider the effect
of substantial performance upon the
express condition that the issuance of
a of the certificate was to proceed the
duty to pay.
One reason for this may be the
case of Nolan versus Whitney,
where the court held that when a
contractor has substantially performed the
contract,
the architect is bound to issue a
certificate and unreasonable and wrongful
refusal excuses the necessity
that the certificate be issued.
Most dates,
however,
have followed the principle of review set
forth in section three Oh three of the
first restatement,
which excuses the certificate of an
architect as an condition precedent to the
duty of immediate payment only in limited
cir circumstances such as the death of
the architect or failure of the
architect to properly examine the work.
And assumption here is that the architect
as a professional should have more
room for the exercise of honest
judgment that has permitted if that,
uh,
then that permitted if the decision
were reviewable under standards of
reasonableness.
Reasonableness.
A second interesting issue
is the seller's duty to sell.
As we just discussed outside the UCC,
a buyer's duty to pay is nominally
conditioned on the seller.
Substantial performance. On
the other hand, a seller,
his duty to sell is normally
conditioned on perfect tender,
a full payment should there
be exceptions to this?
Perfect tender rule where the buyer
is a day late or a dollar short.
Okay.
The Jacob and Young's case illustrates
many important principles in contract law.
It touches on important issues
such as material breach,
substantial performance and remedies.
The court adopted,
adopted a substantial performance rule
regarding a buyer's duty to pay instead
of a perfect tender rule or
an independent promises rule.
Because the plaintiff install the pipe
equal in price and quality to Redding
pipe,
the court found that the plaintiff's
substantially performed his side of the
contract and was not in material breach.
As for damages,
the defendant is only entitled to
dimunition in value and not the cost of
performance.